The sprint is something
that you need to design and
it's the job of the sprint master or
you in this case, to plan the activities
that you're going to do before,
during and after the sprint.
Let me give you an idea of what you
can expect in each of these periods.
First, you should know that you're
going to do a lot of work up front.
In general, you want to spend
about one day of planning for
each day of the design sprint.
Now this will feel like a lot
of work and it should be.
The good news is that good planning will
help you run a smooth design sprint and
let you solve your design
challenge quickly.
Before the design sprint,
you'll want to write a design brief.
This will let you define
your design challenge and
then it will also let you set a timeline
for when you want to launch or when you
want this deliverable, whatever it is
in the design sprint to be reviewed.
Before the sprint, you'll also
want to invite team members or
talent to the sprint.
Nadia will talk more
about this later and
one of the key parts of a design
sprint is user testing.
You need to schedule when users will
take a look at whatever you design from
the design sprint.
The user testing will keep you
accountable, validate product ideas and
push you and perhaps your team
toward showing users something by
the end of the design sprint.
Now this might now make a whole
lot of sense right now,
but I guarantee you it will
by the end of this lesson.
Finally, before the sprint, you'll also
want to schedule any lightning talks
more on this later and
you want to prep the slide deck
that you'll use in the sprint and
leave room for special materials.
In the next video, I'll cover
the details of a design brief and
how you can appropriately
scope your design challenge.
Here are the tasks that you'll
need to do during a design sprint.
If you're working alone,
you won't need to do daily check ins and
daily summaries, instead you should
keep a master list of all the tasks you
need to get done, so
that way you can stay organized.
You should also write reflections after
each day, so you can look back on them
and get better at planning and designing
the sprints alone or with a team.
One of the hardest parts about
conducting a design sprint
is facilitating conversation and
resolving conflict among your
teammates should they arise.
Now you won't really need to worry
about this if you're working alone, but
you will need to be the point person or
appoint someone else to resolve
any conflicts when they do arise.
After the design sprint, you should take
the lead to summarize the results and
plan next steps.
If you worked with a team, you'll want
to send out a short survey to ask your
teammates about how the design sprint
went and what could go better next time.
If you're working solo, then you should
just reflect on what happened and
how you might improve in the future.
And hopefully,
you're already working towards
planning your next design sprint.
All of this should feel like
a lot of work and well, it is.
Thankfully, many other companies
have done design sprints before and
there's tons of great resources and
documentation and
short articles about how
to conduct design sprints.
Global Ventures, for example,
has put together this awesome
list of resources for you.
They also have a great collection,
a library of resources that has short
articles that will walk you through all
of the steps needed to schedule and
conduct user research interviews.
These are also the your
usability testing interviews
that you'll do at the end
of a design sprint.
All of these resources will be included
in a reading node at the end of this
lesson.
They also have a great library
of additional resources.
In this library, you'll find
a collection of short articles that will
walk you through all the steps needed to
schedule and conduct user research and
usability interviews, The links to these
articles will be provided in a reading
node at the end of this lesson.